Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking with
Kelly while who's a journalist at The Daily Beast,
where she covers extremism, disinformation
and the internet. Also author of Off the Edge,
Flat Earthers Conspiracy Culture and
Why People Will Believe Anything.
Kelly, really great to have you
on today. Thanks for having me.
So I want to get a little bit to the resurgence
of Flat Earth specifically because I think it's an
interesting kind of window into a lot of the stuff
that you cover. But if we zoom out a little bit,
you know, when I've spoken to both extremists
and those who cover extremists, often they say
that the folks most likely to fall into these
types of beliefs generally are folks with,
on the one hand, certain personality
characteristics. But on the other hand,
with backgrounds that are often about not having
something that they feel a sense of belonging
towards. And sometimes this relates to parenting.
Sometimes this relates to communities or bullying
in school or these sort of types of things. What's
your sense covering this and researching it about
what makes folks more likely to, as you say
in the title of the book, believe anything?
Speaker 4: Mm hmm. I mean, there are a few
factors, and one thing that I have to flag is
that we're all susceptible to conspiratorial
thinking. To some degree, it's not some
weird thing with tinfoil hat people do. It really
emerges when we feel like we don't have enough
information or the information we have. Is it
comforting for us? It doesn't reaffirm our priors.
But you're right to bring up that sort of sense
of isolation because one of the things that people
go looking for when they seek out flat earth or
another conspiracy theory is a sense of belonging
is a sense of community, and conspiracy theories
often work in this weirdly team based way.
It becomes sort of an us versus them mentality
where you're either on the inside of this small
community that says it has all the answers and the
world is out to get us or you on the other side
and by definition, evil and scheming. So I think
those communities are very alluring for people who
both want community and want answers and
repackages them in a way that I think is
it's very appealing for certain people.
Speaker 1: The comfort thing is interesting
because one of the one of the characteristics not
not a flat earth specifically, but of some other
conspiracy theories, including that random events
were actually planned. What seems to underlie it
is that it's really stressful to think or
to believe that random bad things happen,
that you couldn't possibly protect
yourself from, and that it's sort of
a matter of chance whether you personally
are affected by something or not. It seems
that some people get comfort from believing
it was planned, and at least some people knew
exactly when and how this was going to happen.
Speaker 4: Yeah, and it's weird to think what's
comforting for certain people, because if you
told me that you know there's a whole bunch of
evil doers in a dark room, scheming all these
events was actually the opposite of comforting.
To me, that's a little distressing. But for some
people, that's better than the idea of pure chaos,
right? And they often make it very theological.
You know, they don't like the idea that there's
nobody looking out for them. And, you know, to
tie this back to flat earth. One of the best
reasonings I've heard for someone getting into
flat earth theory is they believe the Earth is
like that. The universe is very small. It's this
little flat earth contained under a snow globe,
basically. And she said that she didn't like the
idea that the universe was so big and so random,
and that she was this little point in it. And when
she compressed all the unknown knowns into this
again really small snow globe that she
realized that she was special and she
had a place in the universe. And so I
think that explains a little bit of it.
Speaker 1: You write about how there was actually
a flat Earth movement in the 1830s, and I think
many people might just say, Well, you know, we
just knew a lot less then. But but actually,
1830 was not the start of when
we started to realize that
the spherical Earth is actually what it is. Can
you talk a little bit about kind of what led that
movement and what the beliefs were based on?
Speaker 4: Totally. So you're right. I mean,
we've known for more than 20 years now that
Earth is round, and it's because it's actually
pretty easy to prove old timey mathematicians
agrees that Egypt, we're doing this for ages.
What happened in the 1830s 1840s was it
was a time of upheaval. It was a time of
technological and scientific revolution. And
that is a moment when people go looking for
alternative answers and as new ideas of science
and evolution were forcing religion to take
the backseat. And a lot of people's minds,
people started looking for reasons to discount
science and. Earth emerged from this really wacky
character who was a failed communist leader, he
sold a fake medical cures for a while. He had
this theory that because Earth looks flat,
it must be flat. And not only that, but it's
that scientists are actively colluding to
hide the reality from you. So for people who
wanted to opt out of new fields of science,
this was the golden ticket, right?
Speaker 1: And when we think about
the resurgence of flat Earth like over the last
six to 10 years, it's interesting that we have
so many more technological means available to us
now and so many different ways to easily prove
that the Earth is not flat. And yet it has still
resurge, but on a sort of different basis, right?
Speaker 4: Absolutely. You know, it's
funny for about 200 years now, we've been
watching flat-Earthers come up with new reasons
to discard new scientific evidence in the
during the space race flat Earth has had to
contend with. OK, why are there pictures of Earth
from outside Earth if we're all underneath a snow
globe? And increasingly, I'm seeing people not
really try to contend with the evidence at all,
but say that any new conflicting evidence is
actually proof of a scheme against them. It's
it's fabricated, it's there to deceive them. So
one thing is that this theory and many
other conspiracy theories are not really
about the prove ability or the believability.
They're about people's willingness to believe
against all odds. And when you get that kind of
motivated reasoning, it becomes really easy to
just chuck out evidence that you don't like.
Speaker 1: You know, in the past when when I've
interviewed experts on conspiracy
ism and conspiratorial thinking,
often we kind of start from the point of
flat Earth being one of the most benign, non
empirically based sort of conspiratorial beliefs,
and that it might exist in a sort of isolated,
benign space. But many of these folks
who who study this say, well, rarely
do people just have one of these beliefs. And
so there is really more than random overlap
between like flat earth beliefs, Illuminati
one world government anti-Semitic beliefs
that all these different things are linked more
than you would expect by random chance. And so
while flat Earth specifically might sort of be
benign, it's often the same types of folks that
go to the flat Earth conferences that are doing
some of the other stuff. Do you agree with that
assessment? Disagree with it. Partially agree.
Speaker 4: I absolutely agree, and I think it's
getting worse, too. I started following Flat
Earth around 2017, and even at that time I
thought it was a little bit more siloed. I didn't
see so much interchange with other conspiracy
theories. Whereas now I see a lot more active
networking. What would have been purely flat
earth Facebook page? 2017 is now sharing a lot of
carbon disempower, thinly veiled Q and on and you
know, and it does make sense in a way because
if you believe in something so literally world
encompassing as flat earth, you're not going to
believe that every other established reality holds
true. You know, flat earth lets you just knock
down all the facts and build your own. And so
it's very easy for people to draw on preexisting
conspiracy theories, and you're right to note
that a lot are anti-Semitic or people of nature.
Speaker 1: One of the interesting things about
Flat Earth is there's there's this kind of common
belief, which I think is borne out by the studies,
which is you can't just give facts to folks who
believe certain things. And sometimes the more
facts you give them, the more they actually resist
changing their perspective. And the interesting
thing in that context about flat Earth is
that the they have rebuttals to just about
every purported rebuttals I think I should say
to just about every empirical claim that you can
present to them with data and with facts and with
observation. And so it's sort of like the perfect
experiment as to what does get folks to revise
their beliefs when it comes to people who were
flat-Earthers but were disabused of those
beliefs. What has worked effectively,
Speaker 4: what is worked with the
X flat earthers that I've spoken to
is not exactly debate because I think when people
debate, they dig into their own beliefs, they
double down. They don't want to be proven
wrong. What I've found has helped in the
limited cases of the conversion is because
I think people need to be willing to convert
is they've had compassionate discussions with
round thirds, people who aren't here to belittle
them or prove them wrong or have one of these
awful YouTube livestream debates. But say, OK,
why did you come to this belief and what
emotionally is motivating you to do this? And
what can we do that's observable to you? Can we go
watch the sunset over the horizon? Will that help
in that kind of compassionate exchange, one that
takes into account the humanity of the person that
you're trying to talk to and the emotional
needs that drive them to conspiracy theories
often? I think is a lot more fruitful than this,
this belittling or keep using the term team base.
But it's conspiracy theories are very team based,
and if you turn it into an us versus them debate,
it follows that that's not
going to convert somebody.
Speaker 1: What are the motives
that flat-Earthers? We'll leave
explain why the powers that be, so to
speak, would want folks believing that the
Earth is actually spherical when it's flat.
Speaker 4: That's a really tough one as one
that I ask a lot of flat earthers and I get a
range of answers and quite a lot of people say,
I don't really know. I mean, the upsetting
answer is a lot of people will say something
pretty anti-Semitic or they'll use
Speaker 1: even though like,
why would the Jews benefit from the
Earth really being flat? But people
thinking it's spherical like, I don't even know.
Speaker 4: Right, right? I mean, you know, it just
none of these theories because they're,
you know, it goes back and is building on
centuries of conspiratorial frameworks. None
of them actually hold up. There's no reason a
religious group would want to disguise the Earth's
shape. But, you know, they'll make those callbacks
or they'll use something a bit more veiled.
The Illuminati, the new world order. They'll
say that maybe we that the powers that be
want to downplay the role of religion in
the world or they want to keep people confused.
Or the best answer I ever got was this guy. So
Platter who's generally don't believe in
outer space. And this guy is like, Well,
what I think is going on is they want us to
believe in space, so they want us to believe in
aliens so that when Jesus comes down again,
we'll think he's an alien, we'll kill him.
Speaker 1: So that's that's pretty
tough to talk someone out of. I mean,
that's the crazy thing about it.
Speaker 4: Oh, that was really rough
because I mean, he clearly thought about this
for much longer than I was ever going to. Yeah,
but the long and short of it is people are really
willing to believe this theory and sometimes the
specifics or even the motivation comes secondary.
Speaker 1: Can you talk a little bit about
the social media platform algorithms like on
Facebook and YouTube and specifically like
with flat? I think many in my audience generally
understand controversy does better algorithmically
so than in general. Platforms will share
articles that are negative, divisive,
et cetera, with no regard for whether they are
accurate or not. But what are we seeing about
these algorithms specifically with Flutter?
Speaker 4: Well, Earth has performed really,
really well historically and social media
algorithms, especially on YouTube. There is
a period from about 2014 to 2019 when Flat Earth
videos got this massive artificial boost. And the
reason is, I mean, YouTube is a company. They want
to make money and they make money from you staying
on the site, watching videos. And so because of
flat earth was something that I am guilty of this,
too. Everybody clicks on at 2:00 in the morning.
Those videos performed very well algorithmically,
and people will get recommended to them even if
they weren't seeking them out. So YouTube did
change his algorithm after tons of criticism by
2019. But the facts still stands for five years.
This was a really just like open fire hose of
flat earth info into unsuspecting people's feeds.
Speaker 1: Last thing I wanted to talk about, can
you talk a little bit about in the in the culture,
in the landscape right now of conspiracy
theories and sort of extremist beliefs?
What are maybe some less known things that
are maybe coming up? I mean, I think Q and on
my audience knows about flat Earth election was
stolen. Vaccines are killing millions, but nobody,
you know, some of the obvious ones I think my
audience is aware of. But is there anything
kind of like up and coming that you're tracking?
Speaker 4: Oh, man. The question is always like
whether to talk about it if it's up and coming
right? You know, I think to put it a different
way. I mean, there are always fringe theories
on the up. What I think is different now is the
their embrace in mainstream Republican politics.
So whereas Q&A with something that was, you know,
on its face, completely absurd and deranged, now
we're seeing this much more wholesale embrace of
things like election conspiracy theories by the
Republican Party. And, you know, as much as I
will criticize things for like social media for
their role and promoting conspiracy theories.
This, I think, is uncharted or recently
charted territory. You mean the
Speaker 1: degree to which the
Republican Party has participated
Speaker 4: exactly the their role
in promoting it and the role and
normalizing. And I think that is pretty dangerous.
And as much as we can rail on the YouTubes and
the Facebooks for promoting disinfo, this is an
integral part of American politics, and it is just
diving all the way in on conspiracy theories.
Speaker 1: Do you have an opinion as to for
how long will they continue with the evidence?
Is it just about to come out? I mean, because
it's we're at 15 months now and Rudy Giuliani
and Trump and I mean, they continue to say,
we're about to get the stuff from Georgia.
We're about to get the stuff from. Does this
have a long life ahead of it, you think?
Speaker 4: I think it does, but not because
they're going to keep claiming the evidence
is coming out. It's like flat earth where the
evidence doesn't really matter. It's an emotional
appeal. Right, right. So after they see this
narrative for so long, it doesn't really matter
that they keep getting this proving because people
believe it. There's enough of this saturation
of a story that people want to believe, and
by that point, they've already taken down.
Voting sites in predominantly black neighborhoods
already have passed legislation that makes it
difficult to send in absentee ballots. And that,
I think, is like the real, tangible
risk of this conspiracy theorizing
as it enables things that are very real.
Speaker 1: Yeah, at this point, it's almost
like they're signaling their membership
in a team by repeating that rather than,
we literally are waiting around for the evidence.
Speaker 4: Totally. If only they were waiting
around because I mean, they'll be doing
that till they die for a very long time.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Kelly Vile is a journalist
at The Daily Beast. The book is off the Edge,
flat-Earthers conspiracy culture and
why people will believe anything,
Kelly. Really appreciate your time.
Speaker 4: Thanks for having me.